there is something more powerful in the
NBA Draft than a human being or a spirit
it is simply the ping-pong ball and
could control your fate I'm sorry
it's a beautiful asset but now we are
going to do a game it is an accuracy
shooting game that has nothing to do
with certain beverages six teams right
here the six team is most likely to get
maybe the top pick which would be you
have you ever played this game before
never played this game before though
that is a good young man's response to
that pick whichever one is less that is
our prediction for where you're going o
to us this is the Miss Cleo of table
games take a shot let's see what happens
gentle attention Ton Ton oh and the
magic have been eliminate hold on what
would you like to say to Orlando Magic
fans do a real low
no but the rest is not happening it's
not happening
I'm sorry Orlando Orlando's out t-wolves
would you like a triangle or would you
like a stoplight uh trying to work all
right good
I need you're a man goes down to the
three final one Lakers Knicks Sixers
these are traditional powerhouses the
follow-through is nice comes down the
Knicks and the Sixers you are gonna be
East Coast with the Philadelphia they're
gonna love you New York they're gonna
stop
the ping-pong balls have spoken Jahlil
Okafor will be playing for the New York
Knicks how does that how does that feel
we need congratulations you just been
drafted how does that feel it was great
yeah ready to see mo Carmelo and I want
to try to want to be a championship and
there it is the postgame interview he's
officially a New York Knick congratulate
thank you give it up
you